it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what in the world its movie fights
everybody
hashtag movie fights live we're not live
today we're pre-recorded but uh you know
what pretend that it's live and just
tweet along and maybe we will respond
also I want to give a shout out to all
nation hoot-hoot hashtag owl nation what
up my go hooligans let's meet our
combatants for the day
Oh stepping outside of the booth to
fight it's my biological father
Scott masse more proof that I I'm a
trained monkey that just says what's in
front of him stepping out of the boots
to fight I think that was there for jte
movie reviews on Collider and he's is my
biological father I sawed up some the
most energy in the feel free to tweet
and ask us so what booth Scott's step
down phonebook right yeah what we're
talking about
given our our our focus today yeah maybe
it was perhaps booth before these things
came along indeed also a close personal
friend of Nicole Kidman Nicole Kidman
yes so sweet I did a Q&A with her for
destroyer at the ArcLight Cinerama Dome
sold-out screening yes 800 people and
she sends me flowers
amazing amazing I'm gonna send you
flowers as well if you win today he's
part of the only stupid answers podcast
with JD Woolridge uh welcome back to the
show Sam basher thank you for having me
first time barracks first time oh it
says here welcome back to the show
Sam great to have you thank you this
redheaded gentleman do the trifecta
I know she made her first appearance in
the debut deathmatch and she showed out
and she is back again to put it down
Clee Wiggins Lee welcome back to the
party pretty glad to have you and
deciding each round is going to be
myself and the dance let's take a look
at the Dan ham holding it down on some
judging and some facts mr. Dan Merle yes
so I maybe should have said this at the
top but if you clicked on it and
probably saw this in the thumbnail we
are talking 1989 the 30th anniversary of
that year dan what were you up to back
in 1989 I was I was falling in love with
Batman yes I was in kindergarten and I
had Batman converse that's what I
remember that night okay since you
mentioned the Batman converse would you
take off one of your shoes and hold it
up for the camera dan is wearing some
dope-ass vans today because that was
spider spider bands
I would never bought this for myself but
I love them yeah more dance I changed in
the last 30 years or will not change in
the power we in nights maybe now you're
just talking about it I don't think that
Oh Scott gotten Bill & Ted's phone booth
I got in the DeLorean and we're back in
1980 I will not have changed in 30 years
old there we go and she is a delightful
angel sent from heaven above and she's
usually the voice of the people but
today she will be sounding off with her
own opinions on the on the rounds
Daniel Radford I think yeah no polls so
will just be me having my own opinions
being a human but yeah please continue
to tweet I would be at the movie lights
live hashtag because we will be checking
those at Bravo chef oh heck yes Danielle
thank you so much again here's how it
works
it's a best-of-seven so the first person
to for first person with four points
takes the game and we're gonna have
three regular rounds after those three
rounds the top two scores will move into
a one-on-one speed round where it's
anybody's game someone can be down three
to zero and make a furious comeback in
the speed round are you guys ready to do
this let's do this Sam Kay let's do this
hey Billy business drop that sick ass
package
all right thank you for the movies
oh yeah all the fight sequences in every
movie ever okay question number one all
right let's just start off with a biggie
shall we what was the best movie of 1989
and we're gonna start with the man to my
left
Scott mance well my son and klee and Sam
here we go the best movie of 1989 you
know when we were first asked this
question it was a no-brainer for me it
was a no-brainer for me to pick this
film is a film that was groundbreaking
trailblazing a movie that still holds up
by today's standards a movie that is
timeless timeless and timely and
relevant not just an 89 but today this
is the landmark film written and
directed by Spike Lee called do the
right thing this is a film about a clash
of races that happens on a very very hot
day in the bedford-stuyvesant section of
New York City Italians african-americans
Asians Jews you name it they all come
together for an explosive film an
explosive film that builds with tension
just fine and is boiling just like the
heat of New York on that fateful day and
builds to a climax that was shocking and
provocative it was then it was now the
movie was nominated for two Academy
Awards supporting actor for Dan
Danny Aiello and for a screenplay for
Spike Lee and this is still Spike Lee's
best movie it is a film that we are
still talking about all these years
later thirty years later because it is
still timely because of the issues that
it talks about I'll get to that soon all
right movie man's coming in with do the
right thing Sam hell of an argument but
let's just bring it back to a second do
the thing that we are all here for to
talk about movies and when it comes to
our childhood what are the most
important ones it usually comes back to
sci-fi you got Star Wars right there
yeah Robocop right there that's right
yeah as a de Lorean de Lorean
right so we head back to the future
coming out with in the 80s and it was a
masterpiece but how can you top that how
could you possibly you stretched over
three different time period
and not only that you you up the ante
when it comes to the character arcs of
all of the characters revenues to Marty
doc and his family and but also and you
get wonderful set pieces of what 2015
might look like look at that fashion
statement and what wonderful suspenders
that young girl has but most importantly
we get to one of the greatest parts of
the first film is the wish fulfillment
of like what if you could go back and
actually like improve your your own life
your family's life but when it comes to
that you also kind of get the like the
oppressed becoming the oppressor to the
tube if we see that and also those
consequences when it comes to seeing
Marty grow up and become kind of a loser
and not being able to really have
control over his own life and so taking
that into your own hands and taking that
story and spreading it out through three
different decades and it just gives you
the perfect adventure and this is
actually not even a contest this is the
best trilogy and this is the jewel of
that trilogy all right thank you Sam
Klee I have thoughts about that last
sentence so my pick for this and we if
you really think about it I'm right and
it's Batman we would not have literally
we would not have had the blade movies
without Batman I don't think we would
have the current Marvel and DC you
whatever you might think about those
cinematic universes without this 1989
Batman really showing us what a comic
book movie actually can be we were left
in a drought after Superman in the 70s
because those sequels although I do
watch Superman to you a little bit more
that's but yeah get kneel before Zod
come on yes I mean you know Terence
Stamp is Terence Stamp yeah so but
Batman 89 showed us what Cosmo maybe
truly can be that it can be good
filmmaking as well as entertaining that
it can be good acting as well as
servicing the storyline and what the
comic books were at that time because at
that time I think there's one the
beginning of the Dark Knight so Batman
89 I really don't have much more to say
about it because I'm right so I don't
know
this is even a fight alright well why
don't we get a load of this fight fight
it out first of all ok CLE I'm gonna go
with you on this yes Batman indeed get
the superhero genre back on track after
Superman 3 and Superman 4 killed that
version of the franchise
Batman is a very good film it's directed
by Tim Burton it was very very very
heavily stylized it was a it was a movie
that took itself very seriously and
showed how great the superhero movies
can be but Batman it doesn't hold up as
well because first of all it's not about
Batman I watch Batman for the Joker I
watch it for Jack Nicholson uh and
compared to many of the superhero movies
that followed including all three movies
of the Dark Knight trilogy the original
Batman doesn't hold up it's a good movie
it's a very good film it's one of the
best of 89 but not the best and I'm
sorry Sam Back to the Future Part 2 oh
yeah first of all back to the future
love the first movie liked the third
film the Western I hate it Back to the
Future Part 2 Back to the Future Part 2
is a mess all of the heart and soul of
the original Back to the Future was lost
in Back to the Future Part 2 because it
was so confusing jumping back and forth
it got too dark
back to the future overall I love the
trilogy because of the first movie and
because of the third I think Back to the
Future 3 the Western is underrated but
Back to the Future Part 2 was a mess
Back to the Future Part 2 Back to the
Future overall it's not the greatest
trilogy not even close the two greatest
trilogies of all time are Lord of the
Rings and Planet of the Apes those are
the three are the two best trilogies of
all time the modern Planet of the East
with Andy Serkis
I have to disagree a little bit also
Batman I do yeah you gotta give Batman
credit because Batman again that's why
we're here
the it and the fact that you could take
a superhero movie and have like a very
unique and distinct style to it it's
wonderful but I have to I kind of have
to agree it feels a little bit soulless
it's it's a lot of a lot of explosions
and pretty colors and beautiful art
style besides that you're thinking of
Joel Schumacher Oh
I can't forget I know those but know
these movies are they're beautiful but
that's about it honestly okay first of
all bad na9 is not a bunch of beautiful
colors it's mostly blue all superheroes
are about their villains no superhero it
doesn't exist without a super villain
because you need a super hero to fight a
super villain but you don't need a super
hero to be a super villain so that's all
if you look at any comic book movie
anytime they only exist because and they
only become to fruition so they realize
their full potential because of the
super villains that come into their
realm it doesn't happen without that so
I'm gonna have to Justin to get your
point boo I'm so sorry thing is that
here is a film that was about us about
us in 1989 and about us now as of let
the police brutality look at you know
two years after through the right thing
came out you had Rodney King and then I
mean over the years between Rodney King
to Trayvon Martin and beyond this is
still something that is happening and is
happening with increasing frequency
which makes do the right thing more
relevant and timely than ever this is a
movie that stirred conversation a lot of
people watch the film and it made them
talk like how can we make things better
it was a movie that touched on something
Back to the Future to a overall back to
the features a lot of fun Back to the
Future Part 2 is a mess one but I could
see why people like it but it's
entertainment
Batman is entertainment do the right
thing is a socially and morally
conscious film that is about us it is a
it is a movie that inspires us to have
conversation to make things better and
is also Spike Lee firing on all
cylinders it was his third movie but it
was the one that really put him on the
map it was nominated for a Palme d'Or at
the Cannes Film Festival that year in
1989 and it was also a film that when I
think of Spike Lee with all his movies
more than 20 feature films more than
more than 10 documentaries very prolific
he could do big movies he can do daring
films and he and he's you know right now
he's scoring with one of his very best
movies one of them black Klansmen
and when I think of Spike Lee I think of
I want to be provoked I want to be
inspired to have conversation I want to
think and thinking is what do the right
thing does and that is why it is the
best movie in 1989 I'll give you that do
the right thing is probably is Spike
Lee's best film I'm not a huge Spike Lee
fan he gave me a B once in a writing
class but that's not why you know at
Clark Atlanta but it is his best film
but when I go to the movies I want I
want to be entertained I can think on my
own and that's what books are for I want
to be provoked every single day over
racist she was all I had to do was walk
outside my house you may not have the
same experience I don't know if that
might be a thing for you guys but I'm
saying what I what what Batman did was
it changed the movie landscape it
changed how movies how especially how
comic book movies were made from there
on out every single clown we didn't get
these campy cartoony comic-book news
ever again not on not alone not on the
big screen we never got those and not
ever in 30 years but we have them for 40
50 years before that and so it
completely changed that landscape and it
completely changed how we see that genre
of movie do the right thing for all of
its thought-provoking you know
intentions didn't really change anything
every movie thinks it can change the
world of that type and it never really
actually does yeah it sparks
conversation because conversation what
does that do it doesn't get anybody I
mean it might inspire a few people and
that's cute but it doesn't actually do
anything if I think a little man as I be
provoked disagree entertained at the
same time I mean I'm all for mindless
entertainment but I am also more for
movies that inspire me to think really
think and have conversation that is more
entertaining to me than anything you
were gonna say so I just wanted to bring
up I wanted to actually piggyback off
your point that no when I go to the
movies to like I want to learn I want to
be inspired and I want to have my eyes
open for the same but really at the end
of the day what sticks with us are the
things that kind of open our eyes to
like a new Fantastic world and also to
kind of just dig it Batman a little bit
have characters that we actually care
about and be an original property that
like these are new original creations
from Kara from writers and directors
about an inferior sequel of the trilogy
no I'm talking about a thorough and
well-made a continuation of original
characters with stories that span over
some what about your Scott go ahead and
make your point and then let's shift
gears into final thoughts I will say
that that 1989's Batman did brink the
genre the superhero movie genre back
after at the last two super Superman
movies were we're terrible but it did
not change the future of the genre that
didn't happen that did not happen until
2000 when the first x-men came out ever
since the first not have gotten that
movie know that x-men what you see about
what the Superman movies came and went
the the first way the Batman movies came
and went with the fourth Batman movie in
1987 the one with the George Clooney
that was terrible and that almost killed
superheroes but no Glenn wait a minute
though it was 2002 x-men that
revitalized everything the x-men let the
Spider Man let to the Dark Knight let's
go ahead and let's go into your final
thoughts final thoughts do the right
thing as a movie that people are still
talking about the issues and the events
that happen to do the right thing happen
all the time they happen everywhere and
a lot of cases these these these events
are referenced in back to do the right
thing these are these are issues that we
see play out in time ever since 1989
when this movie opened it is Spike Lee's
masterpiece it's a masterpiece film from
Rosie Perez dancing to Public Enemy's
fight the power to the big explosive
scene at the end every moment in do the
right thing counts it's a brilliant film
thank you Scott Sam what I need from my
movies is adventure I need scale and I
need characters that I care about and
you get that in Back to the Future Part
2 also with that movie we get part three
which we liked so they kind of you kind
of can't have the two without the three
but also it's just a wonderful piece of
sci-fi that is original to cinema and
hasn't spotted who has actually inspired
many people to actually create career
paths that has changed how we see cinema
and how our movies are made today
thank you Sam clean I'm
going to rebut one of your points and
that back to the I mean Batman did
change it because you would not have had
x-men without Batman which begat blade
which we got the x-men so that's right
there is the point nom and next back
back to the future - I'm sorry it's
trash
it makes promises that movie were ever
fulfilled in actuality Cubs won Cubs won
I mean but it doesn't fulfill any of it
the promise Back to the Future 3 is only
good because Michael J Fox almost died
on that movie that's the only thing
reason why that movie is almost good as
he almost got his neck broken do the
right thing for all of its I it's it's a
it Spike Lee's most iconic film but it's
not necessarily an iconic film in and of
itself I don't see it as being part of
the conversation about race these days
when we're talking about race in cinema
it's one of the ones it's sort of a
little bit of a grandfather of that and
that's interesting and that's fine
that's what I don't good thing it is a
good thing but I would say that I would
argue that Batman is much more of a
trailblazer in its field then that do
the right thing as a trailblazer in its
Lane and that's what my point is so I
would say Batman day is it's time all
right Wow three very different films
some great arguments Dan where are we on
the facts well I mean it's a quality
fight so not really any factual issues
if you're just going to different groups
IMDB voters voted Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade their favorite film like
the Academy Awards chose Driving Miss
Daisy is their picture-perfect image 89
problematic famously not nominated for
Best Picture that year and we talked
about the summer and how crowded the
summers are these days it's easy to
forget how crowded they used to be too
because do the right thing open on June
30th the week before Batman open June
23rd against Honey I Shrunk the Kids
there's to open the week before that
so the summer's always been a crazy
minefield of movies and that was a nice
little trip in the way way back machine
to open in November by the way gotcha
great so yeah we we heard some again
like Dan said this was a very subjective
obviously we're talking about the the
quality of the films and Sam I really
admire your passion for this film but
you were getting hammered on both sides
and yeah when Scott ding you would like
it lost its heart and soul the first and
it was a mess we didn't really have a
comeback for that just that you liked it
so it came down to Klee and Scott and
yeah I I thought Klee made a great point
when she said that
okay maybe do the right thing you know
opened up this conversation at a lot to
say but it doesn't change the
conversation and no film can and you
know what I think that's a good point
what are you gonna do to change
someone's heart sit him down and watch a
movie but that being said there was some
dings against Batman even though it
holds a special place in my heart
the this is it style over substance azar
enough to latch on to at the end of the
day Scott made the best argument to me
that it it's a provocative piece of
entertainment and it's very entertaining
from the Public Enemies soundtrack to
the bombastic
action throughout the film and it is
really thought-provoking and I thought
it it resonated with me when you brought
back just you know when you mention
things like you know Trayvon Martin and
occurrences like that and you go back
and you see what happened to radio
Raheem in doing the right thing I it
really spoke to me because I can I
consider that film what a Spike Lee's
two masterpieces that and Malcolm X so I
thought you hit all the right notes on
that I'm going with Scott and do the
right thing thank you Dan I thought
unfortunately Back to the Future 2 was
the odd movie out for me in this
argument so it was between Batman and do
the right thing for me and I actually
loved the construction of both arguments
and I was I was very convinced by both I
think that the the sort of putting the
the importance to do the right thing
versus the game changing nature of
Batman those were two really great
angles to go at each other ultimately I
think that there were more holes punched
in the fact that while Batman led to a
resurgence of comic book films and
that's in the short term I think the
argument that it itself permanently
changed everything I thought there's
some good knock backs against that and
so I'm also gonna go with Scott and do
write this Scott you take the point
where's point like a year all right so
it is one for Scott Sam and klee looking
to get on the board just just for shits
and giggles what would you have chosen
oh we have time now cuz I don't have to
check in with anyone else yeah
yeah both arguments were great but I do
feel like when it came to some of the
Perry's like kind of the the fighting
back against the other arguments I did
think that Scott did the better job but
they were both really we have that
statistic arguments I mean thank you I
love your sunglasses wait question where
did you see Batman for the first time do
you remember at the Coronet Theatre on
Geary Boulevard in San Francisco County
back to the future in my neighborhood in
Santa Clarita California when I was
three years old I saw do the right thing
at the New Orleans eight movie theater
in Northeast Philadelphia Wow there you
go how about it yeah that's a tough one
your arguments it was like what's better
hamburgers or pizza all right number two
Timothy Dalton returned as
double-oh-seven
James Bond in 99 s licensed to kill had
Pierce Brosnan not taken over the role
what a t-star should have been the next
Bond interesting and we're going to
start with Sam who interesting thank you
so much for having me here I would like
to talk about the king of small screens
big screens let's talk about Sean Bean
for a second someone who's actually
already has a little bit of his own
corner in the James Bond universe for
Goldeneye he was actually considered for
the role of James Bond which was fun
little tidbit that I was able look into
when I was researching this but know
this
this man is Suzy who steps on screen you
understand like that he is a man who
actually has a plan I'm pretty sure
that's what he would be like in his
personal life as well I the way he's
able to take not only his own like maybe
personal sorrow or the Soraa sorrow of
the character but then turn it into
something that you can really latch on
to for with longevity so possibly I
would love to see him maybe do a couple
of these movies but you know too little
too late but no I I think and also we've
seen him go hand to hand with action
when it comes to Lord of the Rings and
we've seen just just as touch of it when
we came to Game of Thrones
he got nerfed a few times so that didn't
last for very long but I think in his
prime um also we see in gold mines well
but we in his prime I feel like he could
have brought something really special
and in some
who really embodies the charisma of
James Bond for that era that's me
alright he's great at dying would he
have been a great bond Klee okay I am
admittedly fighting a bit of a dark
horse but this person was also
considered for the role of James Bond he
actually came in in top three I believe
from if my research is correct and that
is Simon mccorkin bale of Manimal and
Joss 3d Fame there was a short leave
show in the 80s called Manimal where
this guy would turn into Adam show ever
alright and I am just old enough to have
loved this [ __ ] here he was an English
professor who turned into animals and
helped the LAPD solve crimes but he was
very smooth he's very suave he's sadly
no longer with us he died in 2010 but he
would have been a perfect James Bond he
had the look he would have been a bit of
a departure from the dark haired James
Bond's of the past without the big jump
that we eventually made to janya leg he
would have been but to have the same
smoothness and swapna sad I think as
Timothy Dalton and Roger Moore had but I
think he had a bit of a rough edge side
as well as we could see in Jaws 3-d and
Manimal and also on falcon crest time
soap opera it was not Dallas and not
dynasty it was Falcon Crest today
and so I think he would have been he
would've made a great James Bond II meal
as you can see from the photo that they
put up earlier he looks great in the tux
all right CLE uncorking a little
mccorkin down
Escada okay here's my first of all we
are talking about late 80s moving into
the 90s so because of that you have to
look at the time you have to look at the
time at the time not with perspective
now because of what happened to this
actors fall from grace into 2000 so you
cannot include that because you're going
back to the late 1980s and early 90s and
at that time Mel Gibson was one of the
biggest movie stars in the world and he
deserved to be you're talking about an
actor who had death and gravitas in the
road warrior he made two great in just
in the 80s he made two great Lethal
Weapon movies with that really
demonstrated his his action chops his
comedy his charm his sexiness and you
talk about an actor who would look great
in a tux you talk about an actor who yes
he was considered for the role of James
Bond now here's why Mel Gibson would
have been the best of these three
choices because you know what the
Timothy Dalton movies I thought living
daylights was okay license to kill was
bad liddie daylights made 51 million
dollars and license to kill 1989 made 35
million you needed someone to put the
James Bond movies back on track
you needed a bankable box-office
reliable star that everyone loved that
women love and men wanted to be that
person is Mel Gibson he he's
great-looking charming funny sexy has
grit and gravitas obviously could do
action he's has a dangerous edge to him
a dangerous physical edge to him that
would have put him in the ranks of a
Sean Connery James Bond so there you go
all right I'll fight it out y'all okay I
have one thing to say Mel Gibson is
Australian so you cannot join mi6 if
you're not but you know why
he's an actor yeah who was an Australian
and they famously never hire somebody
who's not British to play James Bond
there's been American actors who
considered to be James Bond they
considered P Diddy at one point it
doesn't matter Australian I have nothing
to say about his father he was born in
New York he was raised in Australia just
because just because they haven't they
haven't cast anyone who wasn't British
doesn't mean they wouldn't they just
haven't yet they won't it's never going
to happen
Harry Potter teacher in the if you're
gonna have a Hogwarts teacher be
American it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen
who the hell is Santa working down here
doesn't mean that he wouldn't have made
a great James Bond at the time he was as
famous as Pierce Brosnan at that time
go back Sam I mean Dan check back check
that [ __ ] he at the time he was as
famous as Pierce Brosnan he was on a
bunch of shows he played that crazy
scientist in Jaws 3-d that's what he did
instead of doing James bring people back
in the series no American audience had
never heard of that was Sean Bean and
then they were considering two British
actors who are on American television
shows at that time and that was Pierce
Brosnan and Sam mccorkadale they didn't
do Pierce Brosnan because he couldn't
get out of his contractors revolution so
I think it was their next choice and
they didn't cast him because time
a--they Dalton decided to come back the
only reason why they were even want to
recast in the first place is because
Timothy Dalton that said he wasn't going
to come back here's the second choice
mel gibson for all of it
Mel Gibson has better [ __ ] to do
last time Mel Gibson was considered born
in new york raised in australia we're
gonna say yeah that's not the point if
he was gonna say yes you're asking you
should they have done I'm telling you
Mel Gibson I'm telling you why yeah get
a white if they got a made for very
successful James Bond yes one of them
was good Goldeneye was the only good one
otherwise I felt but he was a wimp he
was not a great James Bond go ahead say
alright thank you alright so while I
agree that Mel Gibson would have been a
smart business decision I feel like he
would have been too expensive for them
where the where that film was that at
that at that point he is such you're
right he's a bankable star but he's
gonna cost too much money and also I
think there might be some weird brand
synergy when it comes to taking that man
who you said yourself he's in lethal
weapon this kind of honestly kinda like
just hobo ninja like coming in and like
being that character that we love in
lethal weapon in those films it would
have been it would have been a weird
choice to make him this swab mi6 agent
it would have been in a bit of weird she
worked like he would have been a
bakeable sorry like I must say I'm oh
your point he would have been a great
bankable star at that point and I think
you made it but but he would not have
made a good James Bond I'm just saying
he walked up here like man I say why why
because I'm saying why he when I made a
gate James Bond because a he doesn't fit
the role he's not suave enough for all
of you he's charming not suave and
there's two different things he's
charming he will charm the panties off
of every person in this room but he is
not suave he's not smooth that's a
bridge and I'm sorry but Pierce Brosnan
and Timothy Dalton and Sean Connery and
even tango Craig to assortments to have
a certain suaveness that I'm sorry that
about Gibson I've heard a lot about
mccorkadale
thank you
by the arguments you guys have done a
great job but I have to say when it
comes to price points and when it comes
to how old the public at the time take
taken that into account it would have
been a weirder sell also don't know who
that is you would have known he's not an
only Sean Bean is it was American
business he would have been he would
have been lesser-known
but so are most of our James Bond's and
we find out how suave and sexy and
mysterious these people are because we
don't know who they are going into the
film we get to figure that out through
the writing of James Bond seeing him go
through these adventures and we know
that Sean Sean Bean has the chops to
pull this off and he has the look that
we need to go into this your guy has the
look as well but he just he doesn't have
this I mean it's yeah yeah you Sean Bean
would have been a beta Daniel Craig and
it's fine I don't know let me let you
have that Sean P Ambrose better as a
villain that's why he played the villain
a goal tonight that's why he played the
villain in a completely different series
if you took shy needs good but he's not
James Bond but had a darker edge which
you say which we have in the Daniel
Craig movies from Sean from Sean Bean we
could have gotten that performance from
that app there are something about Mel
Gibson that is dangerous the way he was
ready to hold the gun to his head just
to be reckoned with in the road warrior
as Mad Max I mean you know he and he
already had at that time three Mad Max
movies under his belt by 91 which are
good but wait a minute the question
isn't what he had been too expensive the
question is what a t-star should have
been we're not talking about brick about
about how much he would have cost who
cares the fact is obviously MGM Eon
Productions the broccolis the producers
they knew they needed to rescue and
revitalize James Bond they double down
on Goldeneye that's why they got Martin
Campbell to direct
that's why it was a big-budget movie and
that is why they tried again and got
Pierce Brosnan because he was free but
they always wanted piers Brown the
get-go he dalton said no so seems to me
dealing said he wasn't gonna be able to
do it
wit for Pierce Brosnan he just couldn't
get out of his contract but I'm talking
about what would have actually been the
smart choice a smart choice because he
was blonde Pierce Brosnan at that time
trust me he was blind here Drazen at
that time you might be hyping him up
just shift gears and move to our final
thoughts Sam we'll start with you
Sean Bean has the dark edge that we want
he he was up-and-coming give you that he
didn't have the notoriety of Mel Gibson
but you don't need that for a James Bond
you don't I don't think that you need
that going into a James Bond role and
Sean Bean from what we've seen through
his just wonderful career as an actor he
has he has the dark ride to repeated
that but also he has the chops to pull
off action scenes and he has the swab
and sexy attitude that you just need
when it goes into the James Bond
character he can wear the hell out of a
suit there you go that's all right point
of the entire thing
Clee so I'm McCrory no can wear the hell
out of a suit too and I think much
better but no Sean I mean the Simon
quirky no can wear the hell out of a
suit too as we saw in the photograph
it's like the first thing they pulled up
obviously it's Google Image searches and
it's time the court Goodell in a suit at
the time he was asked famous as Pierce
Brosnan so he would have been able to
pull off the the notoriety that were
so-called talking about of having a name
for the James Bond franchise at that
time if we're going to back to at that
time and second of all he had already
proven himself to be a SWAT person who
could pull off ridiculous plot
contrivance --is and and and things with
Manimal and falcon crest and then he
went on to do ditch job 3d instead of
what he didn't get James Bond so come on
he got half eaten by a shark and pulled
that performance off like a champion by
the end of 1980 right by the end of 1989
James Bond franchise was pretty much
dead its it would be another six years
before we would see Goldeneye come out
MGM the producers of the Bond series
that
who owned the rights they needed to save
it Mel Gibson would have seated he was
bankable he was a hell of a lot bigger
than Sean Bean he was a definitely have
a lot bigger at Simon mccorkadale
who the hell is this guy jaw street the
Manimal I really a guy
I mean Mel Gibson had it he could do
action he had it all and you know white
in the early 90s at the early 90s if the
news would have broke
nope news would have broken the trades
all over the world that Mel Gibson will
be the next James Bond everybody would
have gone absolutely nuts crazy excited
they would have said Simon mccorkadale
is the next James Bond that would have
been like huh if they would have said
Sean Bean they would have been like okay
but but no kissing with bill oh my god
that's great time all right
Wow that was more fun for me that was a
fun one right there Dan Morel talk to us
about factuality oh so many okay nice he
did he was not necessarily in
consideration to play James Bond he
publicly said I want to be James Bond
he made his own audition tape slash
fragrance commercial $50,000 that he
sent to the producers so it wasn't so
much that the producers were concerning
him the James Bond it was he considered
himself to be Jim
I will say that P Diddy was very
excellent in the Vince Vaughn and Jon
Favreau film made to the Greek yeah yeah
he was great in that yeah dance so the
idea of James Bond's nationality there
have been some non British James Bond's
Pierce Brosnan was Irish George Lazenby
was Australian so there have been
they've always been you know rise to the
UK but they don't necessarily have to be
British there is precedent for non
British citizens being cast as James
Bond and James Bond films so there's
some precedent there now the question
about who was more famous in 1989 was
Simon mccorkadale as famous as Pierce
Brosnan I can't I can't judge popularity
Manimal Ram in 1983 for eight episodes
it was a 90th place Remington Steele ran
for five seasons from 1982 to 1987 and
was a top 25 show so I think it's fair
to say that it's possible I would say
feasible that Pierce Brosnan perhaps was
a better known quantity at that time the
Simon can just pipe in I grew up in the
80s I was very aware I consumed a lot of
TV and my
my biological father I know Pierce
Brosnan and Remington Steele was today's
the first day I ever heard of Simon
mccorkin yeah I just don't know um Dan
thank you please go ahead and now rule
this into you what are your thoughts on
this this was who should it was it
correct the question who should have be
it Ben if Pierce Brosnan had not done it
what a t-star should have been the next
James would have been the next James
Bond I think that everybody made good
arguments for their pics
I actually I could see all of these
choices doing it but I think Scott made
a great argument for why Mel Gibson at
that time where the series was the fact
that the last couple hadn't done well
the fact that there have been
Australians that have played James Bond
before although I know Mel Gibson is not
100% Australian I think that he still
made the best argument as to why Mel
Gibson should have been and not just
could have been James Bond and so that's
why I'm gonna side with Scotland all
right that's one for Scott Danielle oh
yeah this is really everyone really
brought really good passionate arguments
and klee you are like arguing it at a
handicap you are really put this is the
most Simon mccorkadale will ever be
god it's so fun yes I'm going to
actually track that and see if it winds
up going up by a hundred or something
star meter Oh Simon you did such good
work that none of us saw so yeah these
were great the shot at being arguments I
also thought were really fantastic I do
with this what I have to go with Dan
because other than you know the
arguments about like charm and suaveness
and and the type of character Scott also
brought in reasons for why the studio
would want to hire a you know pre before
we knew things 1989 top of the world Mel
Gibson so I gotta go stop all right
Scott Matz vaulting into a commanding to
only taking the points CLE it didn't
help that your guy is just a weird name
Julian's fans I mean Julian Sands 1989
was like 19 years old I knew exactly
what she said the guy who tossed three I
saw him like at the end I am a big Scott
mance is ahead - oh so this question
we're looking for either Sam or Klee to
get on the board here and let's move to
question number three Nora Ephron had a
big hit in 1989 with When Harry Met
Sally oh man what movies came out that
year yes a good year um what two actors
are the best on-screen couple of the 80s
best on-screen couple of the 80s Clee
lay it on us
alright my pick is like Batman
correct and it's Kathleen Turner and
Michael Douglas they did three movies in
the 80s they did the two they did were
mentioned the stone it
admittedly lesser sequel Jewel of the
Nile and the amazing War of the Roses so
those are two and a half fantastic
movies they have great chemistry so much
so that then when they were filming
Romancing the Stone Michael Douglas's
then wife showed up on set unannounced
because she just had a feeling that
something was about to go down and so
she showed up on set you can fact check
that is their readiness zone is one of
the best romantic comedies of the 80s I
would say it may be neck only beaten by
maybe heroine Harry Met Sally or the
Roses is probably like the like the best
comedy about what it's like to break up
as a couple and you know I mean they I
mean it delves it's just some really
dark places but it shows like sort of
the even just the manifestation of the
evil thoughts that can happen when
you're breaking up and you've been
together for a long time and you know
each other's buttons so very well but
they have great chemistry they are super
sexy at that time Kathleen Turner's
voice is obviously amazing Michael
Douglas had a weird sex appeal that I
still did to say cannot quantify is
awesome so they're my favorite couple of
the 80s all right clean coming in with
Michael Douglas and Kathleen Turner
around the horn to Scott mance okay I am
wearing the bling because I wanted to
really support this couple as the best
on-screen couple of the 80s in fact they
started the 80s as the best on-screen
couple on the highest of notes I'm
talking about Harrison Ford and Carrie
Fisher and the Empire Strikes Back now
that's Return of the Jedi but I'm
talking about they should have shown the
picture of the two of them kissing on
the Millennium Falcon in the asteroid in
the Indian pirates back because he's
Cavin huh now they got together they met
in 1977 with the original Star Wars
which at the time was just called Star
Wars no episode for Nova new hope it was
just Star Wars but it was in the Empire
Strikes Back that they really got
together and before they got together
you knew that they belong together you
knew that they were going to get
together they're sparring in the halls
of Echo Base I they were it was like the
throwback to
classic screwball comedies like like his
girl Friday where you knew that they
were meant for each other even though
there were polar opposites and very
different their chemistry was was
president even when they weren't
together and when they got together that
moment on the Falcon was the moment
where the Star Wars series got sexy it
gave the Star Wars trilogy its heart the
love between han and Leia was the heart
of the Star Wars series the the
relationship between Luke and Vader was
the soul of it but the relationship
between han and Leia was the heart of it
the love of it and first of all let my
respects back one of the best movies
ever made period one of the top by
greatest movies of all time at least in
my opinion Ford and Fisher were terrific
together they had great chemistry there
there they were so good together that
after Hahn was frozen in carbonite and
taken away by Boba Fett Leia's love for
him was so strong that you still felt
his presence and that moment in the
carbon chamber where Han says I love you
I mean and Leia says I know is one of
the greatest most romantic moments in
movie history
thank you Scott manse Sam thank you so
much I have really quick love both those
movies we're talking about couples I
want to talk about a movie that is
there's no will they won't be it's just
like this little message in the bottle
sitting out in the universe of we're
gonna see how these two people get
together no matter what the world tries
to thrown their way I want to talk about
Tom Hanks and Daryl Hannah and splash I
rewatched it recently and I did cry I
don't care it's great no the entire
movie it's just seeing how this crazy
fantasy brings these two people who
should never have gotten together
together and they've then and this is
not even like them being as adults and
then bumping into each other at a coffee
shop they met each other as has children
and she saves his life and you get to
see that like he he becomes this like
bumbling very charming nerd trying to
get his life together and he doesn't
even know how to even connect with his
feelings and she comes along and allows
him to open up and just trying to
discover who she is as a person you get
the chance to actually find
who he is as well and it's just like and
not only that you get a fantastic
adventure story and it ends the way that
most of my favorite fairy tales do with
a big question market where you get to
see them going off into the sunset
together and actually getting to be
happy or the there's not really sunset
under the water but you get it spoilers
by the way okay oh no you get in this
movie though it's just it's just a
perfect little touch your heart feel
good warm your soul type of movie and
seeing those two actors on screen
together it makes you buy it and makes
you just kind of fall in love with this
grand mystery and I would love a sequel
by the way we're not doing that question
would love a sequel all right fight it
out everybody okay first of all here's
what I got to say about splash really
good movie I liked it a lot but I said I
cut is it if you know pardon the
expression can I use your word do it is
it iconic no it's not iconic it's good
it's a solid it's a sweet film but it's
not iconic Hanalei are iconic Kathleen
Turner and Michael Douglas yeah they
made three movies okay
romance in stone great film i jewel the
Nile sucked man show them fighting and
show them fighting and it was that movie
was a cautionary tale for marriage and I
wish I'd listened roses I mean different
at each other's throat like how does
that qualify as like a good on-screen
couple that maybe like not like them
together whatever whatever goodwill that
I got from from romance and stone and
sort of maybe held on to after the
disappointment of jewel on the Nile like
I didn't think of them as a couple after
I saw them War of the Roses I didn't
want to think of them as a couple but I
still go back to the empire straight I'm
Return of the Jedi I
you see more of Han and Leia working
together but you know they're already
together and they're great together
they're working together as a team
especially when they're trying to
infiltrate the Imperial base on on the
moon of Endor but it was really in the
Empire Strikes Back where you felt you
felt there their chemistry together like
when they're on the asteroid and and
the Falcon and he's holding her and she
goes let go and he goes sorry sweetheart
I didn't have time for anything else
you know where this is going you want to
go there it does and after it after
they're split you want them back han and
Leia Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher
baby except that he invades her space
without consent and in the Empire
Strikes Back so that's a strike against
them right there second of all that when
we have on-screen couples on screen like
a couples in real life go through a
bunch of up and downs we see their will
they won't they aspect Android and
Romancing the Stone we see the sort of
middle ground which the middle of our
relationships are sort of boring and
stupid in Jewel of the Nile see the
culmination of how early shift can end
poorly but we still get a meet-cute at
the beginning of War of the Roses they
Sheen they meet him she kind of saves
his life because he's about to get stuck
on Nantucket Island or wherever the hell
they are at the beginning of the movie I
can't quite remember and she helps him
get to the ferry on time and they bond
their brains out in the mean time so we
see all of those the two things you
touched on both of you touched on about
your couples and how they made what made
them good we see in every aspect of
Kathleen Turner and Michael Douglas's
on-screen relationships throughout the
three movies that they made together I
do want to say it's not about which is
the best movie it's about which couple
and honestly when you sit when I sit
down and watch Empire Strikes Back like
it feels like they just added that way I
will say they're very pretty people and
they're very talented and you do get
moments where they have they really give
you a good performance but I that's not
something that brings me back to those
movies those actors for who they are as
individuals is interesting but when
they're together as a couple I kind of
just tune out honestly it's not it feels
like they were just trying to correct a
mistake and then they just kind of try
to finish it off by the end of the third
movie and I was watching Kathleen Turner
Michael Douglas because they're together
in those movies being so hot being so
charismatic together than having that
great chemistry that they have together
even when they're fighting with each
other in War of the Roses it still
there's a bunch of sexual tension behind
all their fights in that move
there's a bunch of electricity behind
all the fights in that movie when we see
them in Romancing the Stone it's sort of
the same dynamic but on a much less
dangerous and not you know way and that
they're going to like they clash at the
beginning and she doesn't trust him and
he doesn't he's like who is this broad
who's messing up my my game plan and all
this stuff and they get together anyway
and then we see how it how that pans out
over the long term basically I mean you
could consider those movies a trilogy
almost if you really wanted to one of
the Roses you say how they meet cute the
beginning of the film but what's the
point you know that they're doomed you
know that they're not gonna end up
together you know it's gonna be a really
really disturbing movie I'm sorry but
were the Roses too right I think Danny
DeVito directed that yeah he did it's a
disturbing film like like geez I mean
well I should tell jewel the Nile is a
cash grab I know we're not talking about
who said coming we didn't say happy or
successful couple I agree we're not
talking about greatest movie of the of
these bunches here but to say that the
Han and Leia was wasn't felt added in I
disagree I felt like it was it was what
elevated the Star Wars trilogy I think
it was an expectation it was not no I
mean it doesn't hang on it elevated the
Star Wars trilogy to a level that the
original film did not have and none I
have to say none of the Star Wars films
afterwards have not been able to reach
and it was because of two things I am
your father and I am your father and
because I love you I know that moment
that moment of heartbreak I mean
everyone he was supposed to say I love
you too
and after you know before they broke for
lunch how support ad-lib I know and
Irving Kirchner the director was like oh
my god that's gold and it worked it
still holds up their romance still holds
up their chemistry still holds up it is
and by the way there's no invasion of
personal space there and he was seducing
her and she fell for it it was
consensual so don't say that he invaded
her space she went she absolutely went
for it sky you're on a roll why don't
you go ahead and pull turn this in your
final thoughts I find my thoughts hot
Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher I was
going to actually go with Harrison for
and Karen Allen from Raiders of the Lost
Ark because they were equals in that
movie but I really thought about how
Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher because
they were sparring and they they wanted
to hate each other but they couldn't
resist each other that irresistible
quality we felt it before they acted on
it and we wanted it to happen when it
did it was a reward it was a payoff and
still you know almost 40 years later it
still pays off and an expectation all
right Sam I just wanted to point out
with your movie it's what you do have
slight a slight advantage when you have
three movies to see these actors get to
play off of each other and really grow
and they're able to explore the
relationship but what's special about
splash you say that it's not it's not as
big as star wars I would never like to
try to fight that maybe it's on par with
romancing the stuff but it's it's this
cult classic where even though it
doesn't have the time like over three
movies to explore these two actors
together in these scenes in one movie
you get a full romance and also
sometimes I don't even see the fight I
just want to seem like I just want to
see a couple come together maybe they
have a few problems along the way but
they're able to figure it out and have a
happy ending and in splash we get that
between these two absolutely charming
individuals and she's mermaid I mean
again she's a mermaid spoilers she
splashes because she's a man I took this
question to be what was the greatest
on-screen couple of the 80s and then I
chose these two because they did so many
movies together because their first
on-screen coupling was so successful
that's they were such a great couple in
that movie they were said such chemistry
that Hollywood said let's give these
people two more movies to be together
and that's why I chose Kathleen Turner
and Michael Douglas they had such an
amazing on-screen chemistry and rest in
the stone that that translated even this
as not a good of movie that jewel denial
is that still that chemistry is still
there if you go back and watch it and
then it's still present in where the
rules is in which they are fighting
which every couple does so because so
even though it's not it wasn't it wasn't
planned for them to be explored across
this these three movies we still got
that because they were such a great
couple in their very first onscreen
pairing and I actually almost chose Mel
Gibson and Danny Glover for the same
reason
dynamic duo dan Moreau what we have in
the fact zone
I made again this is uh this is a lot of
preference a couple of things not really
Corrections just just to back up yeah
Nora Ephron wonderful a writer and
director wrote When Harry Met Sally went
on to the queen of rom-coms
definitely in the conversation
definitely in the conversation a
Kathleen Turner that is a true story she
revealed that she and Michael Douglas
were on the verge of starting an affair
on the set of Romancing the Stone
Michael Douglas's wife showed up to her
my turn that they were that they were
still married so she said that she
backed off Kathleen Turner also claimed
that following body heat that Michael
Douglas Warren Beatty and Jack Nicholson
all decided to bet on who would get her
first so she said it was none of them by
the way pretty gross and then what
eventually happened Michael Douglas left
his wife and took up with Catherine
zeta-jones yeah
Danielle your thoughts on this round oh
wow
yeah this is y'all are really bringing
the arguments in the passion with this I
am loving this fight even just getting
to watch them over on the couch I have
notes because I always take notes cuz
I'm a huge nerd dedicated that's a word
for it yeah I really liked everyone's
points Sam I really appreciated your
point about like sometimes you just want
to watch some people be in love and you
don't necessarily want there to be like
a lot of arguing and fighting Scott
you're right
Leia and Han are iconic but I have to
say as far as the points that she
brought up about you know the reason why
they made so many movies because of
their chemistry together what I do think
of a tease couples like it is like she
said I do that is who I think about so
I've got to go with clay on this one
thank you
it's one for Klee Sam I really
appreciate you bringing up and I like
just an underappreciated classic and in
splats just a delightful movie early Ron
Howard directly yeah it came down to
Scott and Cleese Scott you really just
pinned those iconic moments by [ __ ] Klee
like you painted that well-rounded
picture and and I think you brought
across the point that even in War of the
Roses where they're at odds there's
passion and the fighting that you have
to click to be able to have my watchable
fight and I feel like that happened and
I thought you painted the more
compelling picture there I also go with
cle-cle you take the points remains in
the stone is one of my all-time
favorites were my Star Wars leggings hey
can I was like I'm not giving him any so
moving on to the speed round will be
clean Scott Sam thank you for playing
thank you guys I'll come to you for some
opinions along the way but you stay
let's let's win a speed round all right
so here's how it works
I'll ask the question call out your
answers the first person to the first
person that I hear that person will get
the first chance to elaborate on their
on their answer and it's 20 seconds 20
seconds and then 10 second rebuttal 10
second rebuttal all right okay y'all
ready for this I'm nervous but let's go
all right until Dan Moreau is on the
timer got the timer
let's go question one of the speed
around so we saw Sean Connery play
Indiana Jones's dad in 1989's Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade which he
brought up earlier in these movie fights
who should play Indiana Jones's mom in a
movie
Jane Fonda Jane Fonda oh I'm gonna go
with Audrey Hepburn ok Audrey Hepburn
going with dad people that's fine first
your 20 seconds will start as soon as
you speak Audrey Hepburn is dead tonight
she wasn't and I wanted to go with
somebody since John economy he's only
about 10 or 11 years older than Harrison
Ford Jane Fonda is around in the same
that same timeframe so I wanted to give
it another actress that was in that same
realm cause if we're just gonna we're
gonna play with the math let's play with
that damn math at the same time I think
that she would make a great counterpoint
I'm sorry damn okay Audrey Hepburn was
very much alive and she made her last
movie it was either in 1989 or 1990 what
Steven Spielberg in always yeah so why
not work with his Steven Spielberg again
in Indiana Jones you know and in that
year and she would have had great
chemistry with Sean Connery and she
would have had great chemistry with
Harrison Ford she's an icon and she's
old enough to play Harrison Ford's mom
10 second rebuttal she I mean Jane Fonda
also has those same points going for her
so I don't see that as any sort of
negation of my of my choice at the same
time I think that Jane Fonda is actually
within the same age range as Sean
Connery
okay Audrey Hepburn is an icon and to
have her and Sean Connery together in
the same movie playing Indiana Jones his
mother it would have taken the movie to
a whole new level
Jane find also an icon to good pecks but
for me Scott made the better case so I'm
gonna go with Scott one for Scott Daniel
um yeah these were both good arguments
but I do feel like the age thing we kind
of got wrapped up into that where I feel
like Scott had more varied arguments for
why Audrey Hepburn would work so I got
stuff all right
Scott takes the point it's 3-1 this is
game point please I need this to keep
her going
Driving Miss Daisy was the Best Picture
winner for 1989 what movie character any
movie from any decade mmm
would make the worst chauffeur pee-wee
Herman Godzilla Godzilla Scott okay
pee-wee Herman to matching this guy
after pee-wee's big adventure at Tim
Burton's first feature film command sky
driving a car he'd be so annoying and by
the way pee-wee Herman this a natural
person who can't drive a car he proved
they can't ride a bike sweet you drive a
car Godzilla cannot fit into a car boom
you just made my point
wait now it's your turn my point god
he's literally a monster who would just
step on your car eat your card step or
sit on your car or blow up your car with
his fire breath he would make a terrible
chauffeur because he cannot literally do
the job he'd say you've had to be a
human or the ability to drive a car okay
if he's not getting into cars that he's
not a chauffeur he's not a person he's
gonna step in the car so what kind of a
chauffeur is that he has to be in the
car driving pee-wee Herman can do that
and he's one of the most annoying people
on the face of the earth and that
qualifies ten second rebuttal CLE I mean
if we're going with Petey Herman and
blow he can't drive a car and not being
in a way person he'd just be a little
bit coked up but Godzilla literally hit
onto the job so he there was no part of
that question that said that it had to
be a human person who was capable of
driving a car you just said he can't do
the job okay okay
okay so we've got a oh we got we started
like parsing or words and semantics of
if you hire him for a chauffeur you know
what um if I'm like okay Godzilla's my
chauffeur like I could still call him a
chauffeur and he could still not do the
job so I think you could conceivably uh
he would be a terrible chauffeur so I'm
trying to say also it was Paul Rubens
and blow not pee-wee Herman you know
like a huge drug deal going down it's
like with Godzilla cuz he would be a
terrible I would never get to work
[Music]
okay that's your argument I heard her
damn I'm just sitting here trying to
decide if please answer is the worst
judge here hurry or the best oh she's
gotta get on that board right on that
I'm gonna say yes so I'm gonna go clean
[Applause]
show Farid step on it all right it's
three to two little game point CLE you
need this to tie it up Scott you need
this to take the game better nineteen
eighty nine kids film Brave Little
Toaster or all dogs go to heaven
although it's gonna have it goddamn it
alright I've seen Brave Little Toaster
well okay usually you don't admit that
to life okay so we heard Scott first
with all dogs Cleese on dick Scott ok
all dogs go to heaven is a minor
animated classic directed by Don Bluth
who was an animation pioneer and
definitely a successful animated film
maker it had a great great voiceover
cast I believe Burt Reynolds was one of
the voices in that movie it was a
charming film a film that still holds up
and who doesn't love him to be about
dogs for my turn
Brave Little Toaster like I said I've
never seen it but I'm going to assume
that it probably smoked a lot of
imaginations because who what other way
would you want to watch a movie that's
literally about a toaster so I think it
was parking lot a lot imagination in
kids when I think all kids entertainment
should at least have some sort of
educational aspect or any aspect that
sparks their thought processes and helps
them develop brain synapses it's not
hunky look ok hard to argue for a movie
you've never seen go to heaven and again
I remember in 1989 when I was old jeez I
was a 21 and I saw it I thought it held
up as a grown-up it well I was a little
bit old to see Brave Little Toaster in
1989 so that's where I've never seen it
but I again I argue that a movie should
spark a kid's imagination and I feel
like any movie that's call Barry low
saucers should do that alright
Danielle qui I love your face
I love I love that we go from literally
arguing that you have the best strategy
in the game immediately admitting you've
never seen the movie it's kind of hoping
she would just start making up her own
plot points at one point true story all
dogs go to heaven it's and it's a phrase
that I use to this day
Scott mance you take movie fight to my
gracious competitors thank you to the
dance
yeah please tell us about where we can
find you okay well you find me right
here because I'm sitting here next to
you and yeah I've really I mean it's my
first time really like chatting with you
about movies Queens same with you I've
got to have you on my movie review show
which I host for Collider Collider video
it's called movie review talk every
Friday morning I tape it live at 9:00
a.m. and you can also follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at movie manse and
you could probably catch me at a lot of
the theaters in LA moderating post
screening Q&A is with actors and
filmmakers yeah um you do a wonderful
job at that and yeah I'm finding at the
ArcLight or wherever talking to Emily
Blunt Nicole Kidman is Scott great to
have you
Sam um so many good choices today so
many good points thank you for being
here good for you please give some
shoutouts tell us where we can find you
oh yeah you can find me at only stupid
answers everywhere that matters it's a
podcast talk about movies TV shows comic
books I'm over at new rock stars as well
those are the breakdown videos it's like
where the easter eggs are in this
trailer if that's them your guy for that
one and you can just find me at Sam
basher everywhere else that matters
awesome Sam thanks for being here
brother Nicholas and Cleve Wiggins oh
you really brought it today you thank
you from my crushing defeat of the last
time well consider yourself redeemed and
we love to have you back please
I get some shouts and whatnot I just
follow me on the social media is at
Cleve the pimp SF on Instagram and that
clean the pimp on Twitter I'm on a bunch
of different podcasts as mostly as a
guests I don't really host my own
podcasts these days but you can follow
the kleenex show page on Facebook we're
gonna start and try posting our
arguments on there again like we used to
with mr. Luthor a great friend of the
family yeah friend of the show ed Grier
and you can like if you want to catch me
on other podcasts starwars minute does
one I've been on quite a few times so
there's like you argued against hot away
how dare you show like 15 times
sometimes the movie fights desperate
times calls for desperate measures yeah
um clean thank you so much let's go to
the bank am dad thank you so much
reporter Dan any anything you want to
shout out today love and happiness
yes oh yeah love and happiness great
stuff like happy birthday Dan hashtag
everyone watching everyone listen to
make sure you go on Twitter and
Instagram or when or facebook or myspace
they're still using it and give everyone
a happy birthday Dan hashtag yes it's
gonna be funny is if this airs in July
I'll take the birthday wishes anytime
half birthday that keeps on giving
Danielle Radford thank you for holding
it down there with your own opinion
today without the without the polls a
person yes true story
yeah you can begin just find me and all
the socials at Daniel Radford on
Instagram I'm at Danielle underscore
Radford I do have a patreon where we've
been watching I have been expanding
beyond wrestling because I realize a lot
of people are like I really like you but
I'm not gonna listen to you talk about
wrestling girl and I was like point
taken I guess for everyone so I've been
doing a lot more like live chats of
different movies so yeah if you want to
hang out with us over there it's really
really fun any other some wrestles but
you know I'd like to mix it up now like
what I'm singing of fun people to hang
out with Daniel Daniel Reverend just
like talk about a movie and make fun of
us that sounds awesome
that's literally we did the Christmas
prints too with me having never seen the
Christmas prints one and I will never
see the Christmas it was amazing that
sounds great oh my gosh those hallmark
movies they're amazing you guys are all
amazing and y'all are amazing for
watching thank you for watching movie
fights shout out to Al nation who who
personable in the house and hit me up on
Instagram and Twitter at Hal Rudnick and
big thanks to Billy biz doing a double
duty on the board and producing today
and thanks again we'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
you